previously on TV since well great okay
someone explain why a bounty hunter
would tolerate a piece of fabric
flapping on his back and getting in the
way of basically every movement and
don't tell me it protects him from the
elements because clearly the wind is all
up in here what is with this dark
vignette filter around the edges of the
screen it is purposely present the
entire episode it was a bad choice it
makes every scene feel darker and more
claustrophobic than it needs to Seana I
don't know what musk is supposed to
refer to but I do know young and sweet
were used in the comment and I'm not
okay with that
what no subtitles now I mean
instinctively I know what he said
because my mother yelled this at me
daily my entire life here I'll fix it
there we go
surely there are a hundred better places
for Quarren to be considering this is a
nice planet and his moist delicate
tendrils would be sticking to every
metal surface instantly to be fair
having a door that operates like that at
a bar seems like it would bail safety
protocols if drunk people are operating
that door every night there is zero
chance this has never happened before
but with that being said how would mando
know that shooting the doors power
source would automatically close it or
bypass whatever sensor that would keep
this entryway from being a regular
deathtrap it could have just left it
open or malfunctioning wear it open and
close like my sphincter after Thai food
spurting like this dead corpse I
appreciate his focus on the bounty but
what about the zipline grappling shooter
he should be pressing a sweet Auto
Retreat button or comically wheeling
that thing in with squeaky noises we are
not seeing Pedro Pascal beautiful mug in
the scene or any scene of this episode
for that matter is that a bounty [ __ ]
yes yes it is and Star Wars is just
getting lazy with their name because
calling these bounty pucks is frankly
really stupid also mithril must know
that he has a bounty on his head and the
moment the Mandalorian stepped into the
bar I'm certain he would have recognized
him as a bounty hunter why didn't he
make a run for it it's got to be a back
door bringing an alarm
no matter how you dress it up that's
still oh we can do this the easy way or
we can do this the hard way cliche fun
fact in order to leave the bar they
would have had to step over two halves
of an entrails seeping corpse because
this showing plant you would think
Automobile Dealers of the frozen tundra
would at the very least have vehicles
with tops on them this is insanity mando
and his
he will die of hypothermia in the
speeder before they even get to their
destination I fire you everything we've
seen is ice so this warning is a waste
of air and esophageal leopard also this
advice proves to be terrible because
this guy wasn't even on the ice and he
got I mean Dan and those are some
perfectly white teeth
tell me about dentistry and teeth
whitening in this world because these
are some impressive chompers and
suddenly nothing else matters you've
been captured by a bounty hunter who may
or may not kill you and you have
discovered a closet filled with weapons
why not take one to defend yourself what
else are you looking for down here also
how did he know how to open this console
are we out of yata in our way around
this huh this feels a lot better
solstice oh god it's like the granola
folks sharing about what it means to
live off the land and their insta
stories I don't wanna see you pee off a
cliff I don't want to see your goats
mating I do want to know how you make
organic candles though so stick to that
for [ __ ] sake I guess nothing happened
this year probably why wouldn't mando
start here what was the point of letting
him sit up in the cockpit with him well
he flew if he had this capability on
board it was fast
Carl Weathers is not fighting a predator
or a Russian in this scene everyone's
face is distorted from the cryogenic ice
blast so how's this face scan helping to
identify the contents with all the
technology available wouldn't a DNA
reading be far more accurate do you want
to chip or not [ __ ] yeah
I've turned on my screen brightness to
max and pray to the Lord of Light but I
can't see a goddamn thing with this
vignette filter and yes I know I already
sent it but now that my eyes are
strained I'm really annoyed longer than
needed shot on a group of stormtroopers
because we're supposed to fanboy out and
just all over ourselves because
stormtroopers what else did he say
he said you were the best in the parsec
god bless you Verner Herzog acting in a
franchise you probably know nothing
about killing it let's see the Bach we
can only offer you a tracking fob
so is he picking up a Honda Pilot
seriously who named it what's the wrong
code we can only provide the last four
digits I don't know how you can track
down in this neck of the woods but I'm
assuming if mando asked for the chain
code and he needs the chain code so why
is shrimp Lee pitbulls ring around with
him here doesn't he want baby Oda who
doesn't want baby Oda see it's okay
because the creatures were with Java so
they're bad this means we can torture
roast them in front of their loved ones
and don't have to feel horrified his
armor is upgraded with what he's brought
in and my question is what would these
fancy Hotel soaps become I'm banking on
proper gel insoles and damned if I'm not
this is totally avoided this was
gathered in the Great Purge good to see
that purge night carries over from
galaxy to galaxy and Mandalorian already
have masks to wear how convenient that's
good I always wants a family
I know foundling flashbacks flash links
down Dax we are all imagining our own
version of what is behind this mask
I think it's pickle rect and now this is
far more interesting and entertaining
you are a bounty hunter yes I will help
you
this actually feels like something Nolte
might do when he's not acting just
hanging out the forest and when someone
randomly wanders into his area he offers
to help them even though they never
asked for it
that's sonal tea did you help them yes
they died I don't know if I want your
help
bando would be excellent at TV since
learn you can keep them both no you
don't need one to ride the way it's
impossible to pass without a blurred
mount if this is true how does the
bounty Droid make it better question why
not Zippity do your ship all the way
over I have spoken but nobody knows how
you were able to speak so clearly
considering the rigidity of your lips
this creature goes from attempting to
rip an arm off to saddled and happily
hopping through the desert and maybe two
hours tell me it drank something to make
it more docile tell me once you tried to
kill it you're the Alpha otherwise this
entire scene is a throwaway attempt to
westernized Star Wars moment of silence
for the costume department for
forgetting his pauldron and his on his
right shoulder and why did you guide me
they do not belong here there'll be no
peace and tell them God got it murder
for the sake of peace why haven't you've
been wearing your goggles while
traversing the desert are these cosplay
goggles made of glitter and drinks I
have never met a Mandalorian I've only
read the stories if they are true yeah
but you told mando earlier that you had
helped all that it'd come through so you
still haven't answered why you helped
them I refused to believe the
Mandalorian is in a hurry
it clearly washed all the mud and animal
poo out of his cloak before taking this
journey I don't care that we saw this
guy as a human being in a flashback he's
a cyclops why else would he looked
through a telescope like this the click
in the droid
I mean how dumb do you have to be to
drop in on an active murder bot and also
how convenient that he was shot on the
shiny new armor
mando somehow surviving this other
disengage self-destruct initiative when
did you ever engage it though kept
telling mando you were about to and then
we'll do something else whoa whoa whoa
there trigger happy you know your mark
is in the room and you want them alive
many centuries
oh it's Yoda look at him such a cute
baby well that means what is this Bubba
Fett sweet
I wonder how they'll tie and Luke and
everything guys I'm gonna with you comi
arrayed before the dark side consumes
you whole
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no droids these aren't the droids you're
looking into hot my name is Walter
Houghton Hoffa and I'm in the
pharmaceutical business anyone else
anyone anyone's seen this before